A word about API's.
I've mentioned it requires and provides part of the components description.
This is sometimes called the component's application programming interface or
API. If you look at documentation for systems at the level of Javadoc for,
let's say a bunch of software you may download. The description of the,
of the classes and what their methods are and so on, are this,
is that, is that classes API. It's going to include the names
by which you can refer to the elements of that particular unit for example,
the method names, the arguments you,
you provide to that component, and, and their types, the return value and
so on. The API could be specified in a particular programming language.
If, if it's, if that's the case, it's called the language binding.
It might be described that a higher level of abstraction, such as using OCL. And
a little later were going to look at specialized notations for describing APIs
at the architectural level called Architectural Description Languages, or ADLs.